I have the honor and privilege of
addressing this gathering of thinkers
and doers movers and shakers in
positions to influence the direction
that our world will take in the
foreseeable future there is a huge
opportunity in Asia this is a region of
transformation and inspiration the
symbol of the ASEAN communities ish
about 600 million people the combined
gdp of nearly 2 trillion u.s. dollars
the future of the region will be shaped
by connectivity and the World Economic
Forum is connecting the region's leaders
from civil society governments and
industry when you have people post
different walks but coming together and
interacting and really learning and
understanding about each other's culture
and really trying to see how we can get
more investment and increase trade
opportunities this is not only a meeting
such as a catalyst for actual for
initiatives and public-private
partnerships the best way but a simple
goal is to go to get it that will enable
us to bridge the gap between potential
and fulfillment
you